all right Mike bro our friend joins us
right now sir great to have you have you
you know my background I spent nearly 20
years of my life uh restaurants uh
construction I think the best greatest
experience in my life
um because I got to know what real work
is and uh and that's what I love about
Dirty Jobs and you know Deadliest Catch
I love those shows I love those guys
um and they they are the people that
make this country great micro
well you're not alone Sean those shows
worked I think on some level because
they reminded a lot of men and women of
a time in their life when the world made
sense when you got up early and you
stayed late and you paid your dues and
you could see the progress you were
making and you could work with your
hands and your mind at the same time and
there were no stigmas and stereotypes
and nobody had their thumb on the scale
those shows did way more than I'll ever
be able to do to start a conversation
around the definition of what a good job
means but today you and I have had this
conversation offline before there's
there's never been a more important time
to have that job especially when you
look at the disparity between the
crushing debt that comes with so many
four-year degrees and the opportunities
that accompany so many vocational
Pursuits you know and and there's a
certain sense of Pride I I kind of had
an eye for finishing work be it when I
was a painter when I hung wallpaper when
I laid Ohio
and I did remodeling work or I built a
deck whatever it happened to be you know
at the end of that day I get to all of a
sudden lift my head up and look around
and say you know there was a certain
amount of gratification Pride if you
will not in a bad way that you know wow
you know we got accomplished a lot today
I felt that people ask me people ask me
all the time like what did you learn
from 350 Dirty Jobs over over 20 years
and the honest answer is you learn that
you like currently that's what you
learned
well you know what this desk this desk
looks the same at like six in the
afternoon as it does at six in the
morning you don't have a lot of visual
cues in your life to know when you're
done but when you're on a crab boat when
you're building a bridge when you're in
a ditch right you always know how you're
doing when you're when you're building
something you're you're a wash in
constant feedback and it's easy to
forget you know what those benefits are
we've got two 2 000 people have gone
through our program and I Circle back
now and I talk to a lot of them and
their story Sean I'm telling you I
should introduce you to a few of them
welders four or five years in the trade
women making a hundred and sixty
thousand dollars a year Crush that's
awesome you know these stories they just
need to be shared they just need to be
told that's what we're up to you know
when when I'm watching either dirty jobs
or you know my favorite Show's Deadliest
Catch
um I still haven't I haven't got my
poster yet I'm just saying I I'd made a
deal oh well why is it there not why
shouldn't I be holding that up
um for the same reason you're very
generous check isn't here either I was
just waiting I was just waiting the
money's been sent I've had it confirm
twice what did you spend it on you know
a night on vacation or what I'll double
check for a third time I spent that on
crabs
all right here's the and by the way it's
my pleasure this is a great charity uh
your work scholarship I love it and I
hope people will help you but for
example if I'm Watching Deadliest Catch
and I watch these guys in the Bering Sea
and they're dropping their their crab
pots down when they finally get there
and they're pulling them back up and
there's nothing there I'm like I'm
living emotionally with them I'm like oh
no oh but when it comes up and it's a
full pot I'm like yes come on let's go
um I'm so happy for them because they're
that is as we both know because they've
lost a lot of crew members over the
years you know that is dangerous deadly
work it is not safe and that
and that show Sean is going into its
20th season just like dirty jobs and it
and it's a testament not to the people
on it quite frankly or or to the format
it's a testament to the fact that you
can't script the Bering Sea it's a
testament to the fact that that show
like life is not just one success after
another we see the failures we see the
struggles we see the character emerge we
get to know these people we become tied
to them you know so look there are a lot
of different ways to tell a story you do
a great job in your format I do what I
can over there with Discovery with the
foundation that's yet another way to do
it you know real stories about real
people mastering a skill that's in in
demand and then and then living a
prosperous life as a result it's true
we're going to give away another million
bucks next month over at microworks.org
anybody watching who wants to learn a
skill that's in demand apply the money
is burning a hole in my pocket in much
the same way that this poster is just
waiting to make its way to your uh Your
Den or your study if you really didn't
get it Whatever It Is
but it's my pleasure to support your
charity and and I will make sure
personally if I have to deliver it
myself because I really support this
work but it really was life-changing for
me and I know that you're changing lives
and you know a lot of these skills and
trades uh as you rightly point out
they're paying you know their heart
their career jobs a hundred thousand
dollar plus annual jobs with benefits
and you know I mean people are doing
great they can get a truck and a home
and have a future for their kids and
grandkids you know a lot of them making
real money and I hope people take
advantage of it where can they find out
how to sign up
microworks.org you can apply for work
ethnic Scholarship today you can donate
if you feel like if there's no pressure
there's so many great causes out there
and Sean can I have 10 seconds just to
say one real quick thing about that last
segment yeah
I I know that made a lot of people angry
it made me angry watching it my heart
breaks for those for those parents and I
just interviewed a guy Lieutenant
Colonel a guy named Scott Mann who wrote
a terrific book called operation
Pineapple Express and it tells the story
of how they got 500 friendly Afghans who
supported us while we were over there
the story of how they got them out of
that mess at Abby gate how they
literally saved their lives this story
is is big and it's important and I know
it's not what we're supposed to talk
about but that no that was a very
familiar with that makes an impression
anyway love to see you Mike Rowe
appreciate it
the Poster's on its way stay on it Sean
I appreciate it too you bet thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else